35 years after the original top gun tom
cruise's maverick has a lot to teach the
next generation of pilots but he also
still has a lot to learn from goose's
legacy to iceman's advice to the meaning
of that final battle this is the ending
of top gun maverick explained
warning spoilers ahead
at several points during top gun
maverick we see maverick almost lose his
wings within the navy forever it happens
at the beginning of the film when he
takes an unauthorized test flight it
happens later when he dares to challenge
the restrictions of training and it
happens once more when he finally loses
his cover within the navy with the death
of friend and former rival iceman who
used his status as admiral to protect
maverick this is of course the ultimate
threat one can level at him as maverick
emphasizes repeatedly that flying is all
he knows how to really do well he spends
the whole movie fighting off the idea
that he might be out of the cockpit for
good until he's finally proven himself
enough to fly as team leader
on the mission at the heart of the film
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
a few hiccups aside the mission is
successful and maverick returns home a
hero after that the film doesn't really
tell us exactly what he's going to do
next in terms of his career but we do
see him back in his hangar working on
that old p51 mustang he's apparently
been fixing up for a long time it's not
definitive proof that he's moved on but
watching maverick take to the skies in
the mustang rather than an f-18 or
another experimental aircraft for the
navy suggests that he's begun making
peace with the idea that he doesn't have
to be a naval aviator forever by
finishing the mustang he seemingly
finished that chapter in his story
one of the key tensions in the film is
the relationship between maverick and
bradley rooster bradshaw the son of
maverick's former navigator goose who
was killed in action in the original top
gun film in the wake of goose's death
maverick did his best to step in and be
a kind of surrogate father for his best
friend's son but at some point that
instinct went a little too far the film
reveals that rooster is still angry over
his father's early death and also angry
that maverick pulled his application
paperwork from the naval academy setting
his whole career back by several years
because maverick himself didn't think
rooster was ready the film presents a
journey for both men not just as
individuals but as teammates as maverick
has to learn to stop handling rooster
with kid gloves and rooster has to learn
to stop holding a grudge it takes a long
time for them to figure this out but
when they're shot down together behind
enemy lines they manage to build what
looks like a lasting bond rooster's
presence in maverick's home at the very
end of the film and his pictures on
maverick's wall suggest that he'll be
sticking around with his surrogate dad
for quite some time to come
penny benjamin is a character referenced
in the original top gun as one of
maverick's exes indicating that these
two have a decade's long history that
penny is eager to put behind her
throughout the film even as maverick is
back in her life she repeatedly warns
him from making further advances
eventually of course it's clear that
something else is happening
and when they get back together maverick
makes a promise he won't leave again
he eventually keeps that promise by
returning from his near-death experience
on the mission only to find that she's
departed on a sailing trip presumably
because she assumed he wouldn't be
coming back at the end of the film it's
penny who returns to maverick not the
other way around suggesting that they've
finally managed to overcome their
hesitancy maverick's willingness to take
her up in the plane he's restored with
his own two hands further cements the
bond they felt they're both ready to
settle down and settle down with each
other
when he's first introduced in top gun
maverick rooster is very much a foil for
maverick a painful reminder of what he's
lost and the ways in which he's failed
in his life but rooster doesn't just
exist to serve maverick's character he's
got struggles of his own to go through
in the training flights for the mission
at hand we see rooster emerge as the
most cautious of the pilots in the field
the one who'd rather take his time and
deal with known issues than fly into the
unknown or rush to action this prompts
maverick to constantly tell him to focus
more on doing than on thinking it's hard
for rooster to make that shift even as
he sees his fellow pilots doing it
around him only when the mission is on
the line and it's clear that he has no
other choice but to act quickly and
decisively does he emerge from his shell
to become the kind of pilot maverick
always knew he could be by the end of
the film rooster has emerged as a more
self-assured version of the pilot he was
at the beginning of the film he's
learned to let go of his fears and he's
also learned to let go of some old pain
leaving him better for it
in the beginning of top gun maverick
maverick's been working as a test pilot
for the navy for years spending his days
pushing the limits of new aircraft as
far as they can go but as we soon learn
the program where he's made his home is
about to be scrapped in favor of
unmanned aircraft something he's
determined to prove he can stop maverick
fails to prove himself better than an
unmanned program crashing the
experimental jet and leaving an admiral
very angry with him
he shipped off to top gun for one last
mission but he proves himself there
establishing the ongoing value of pilots
and cockpits even in an age when drones
can do a lot of the work
i have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
the gold order is never
we see maverick's value to his mission
in the film but one thing that remains
unaddressed is how the test pilot
programs will be affected by his
performance will he be able to advocate
to higher ups in the navy for continued
use of pilots like him
can he save the jobs of the people he
used to work with or is his ability to
move on from his old gig a sign that
everyone else has to move on too
though maverick and rooster make up the
core emotional narrative and top gun
maverick they aren't the only pilots in
the game
maverick works with several of the
world's best fighter pilots throughout
the execution of the mission and they
all seem to have something to contribute
what do they call you bob no your call
sign
bob literally
phoenix and her weapons systems officer
bob bring a steadfastness and
cool-headedness to the team
while payback and his own wso fanboy
bring a certain swagger to the team in
the final mission they each have their
role to play and by the end they've all
made it through it's clear based on the
stakes of the mission that each of these
pilots will have their lives forever
changed by being part of it they'll get
promotions and commendations they'll
take their valuable experience onto
other missions and they might even prove
to be the next generation of top gun
heroes and instructors who will teach
the next class of great pilots how to
fly
maverick's legacy is much more than his
own achievements he's created a whole
new group of mavericks to fly behind him
in the original top gun film maverick
faced off against iceman a cocky
immensely self-confident pilot who
antagonized his competitors and did his
best to get an edge over everyone no
matter what you want to know who the
best is
that's him iceman
that's the way he flies ice cold no
mistakes
in top gun maverick that role falls to
hangman a hot shot young pilot who when
the film begins is the only active
aviator of his generation to have a
confirmed kill in combat he brings a
tremendous ego to the training flights
for the mission often showing an
unwillingness to work as part of a team
and as a result he's left on the backup
crew when the mission finally flies out
near the end of the film but hangman is
not content to stay on the sidelines he
still has a part to play and he finally
shows it at the very end of the battle
when he saves both maverick and rooster
from an enemy jet after their own
hijacked f-14 runs out of ammunition
he does it with his usual swagger but
also with a demonstration that he knows
when to be a hot shot and when to be a
teammate
hangman's got a long way to go but by
the end of the film it's clear that he's
willing to change if it means being a
part of something greater than himself
we don't see a lot of iceman in top gun
maverick but what the film shows
delivers some interesting context about
his place in the film's universe and in
maverick's story he went on to become an
admiral and the commander of the pacific
fleet
and yet he's still in maverick's phone
simply as ice implying the closeness
they reached at the end of the original
film has continued in the intervening
years when maverick visits him at his
home and finds iceman dying the two
share an embrace and an intimate
conversation
suggesting that neither has forgotten
all that they've been through together
when iceman dies later in the film it's
a wake-up call to maverick that he needs
to prove he still has what it takes to
be a leader and a teacher but it also
feels like something larger iceman and
maverick represent two different paths
taken out of that original film one who
became a leader and the other who stayed
in the pilot seat determined to control
the only thing he was ever sure he was
good at
iceman's legacy within the film is a
belief in the sustained power of human
pilots but also a belief in the
sustained power of learning to teach and
help others something he finally taught
maverick in the end
the mission at the heart of top gun
maverick is a complex dangerous combat
flight to destroy another nation's new
facility for enriching uranium before
said uranium can be deposited at the
site it's a tricky ride full of
surface-to-air missiles and enemy planes
so the top gun crew has to do their best
to prepare for every facet of it the
mission is of course ultimately
successful the facility is destroyed and
several enemy planes are shot down in
the process this of course raises the
question what are the geopolitical
implications of this operation it
obviously happened under deep secrecy to
the point that the enemy had no inkling
it was coming until a series of missile
strikes launched to slow their air
response the film doesn't tell us which
country is responsible for the facility
or how delicate u.s relations are with
them outside of this particular issue
it's possible the pilots at the heart of
the mission may have many more combat
flights in their future or it's possible
it'll all just go away because no one
wants to admit to building the uranium
facility either way it's fascinating to
think about
in the original top gun film it was
understood that these pilots and the
institution which trained them would go
on seemingly forever with no challenge
to their necessity or their power within
the us military complex
by the time of top gun maverick that's
at least somewhat in question
maverick's test pilot work is being
undercut by drone programs
and while that doesn't necessarily apply
to top gun itself he also spends much of
the film butting heads with cyclone
top gun's apparent commander who has
little respect for maverick himself and
believes that his style of flying and
teaching is about to go the way of the
dinosaurs end is inevitable maverick the
kind is headed for extinction
by the end of the film of course cyclone
grudgingly grows to respect maverick's
unorthodox methods and his abilities as
both a pilot and as an instructor he
teaches by getting up there and doing
things no one else dares to do and by
ultimately proving that his way of doing
things is still valuable to the navy
it's hard to imagine a world in which
this doesn't have an impact on the
immediate future of top gun its students
and its instructors given how little we
know about maverick's own work with the
navy after the events of the film though
it's hard to pin down exactly how that
impact will land
in the middle of top gun maverick when
maverick goes to iceman's house to talk
through his difficulties with the
mission and with training the pilots
he's been assigned maverick tells iceman
that being a pilot is not what i am but
who i am
he emphasizes that he's not a teacher
that he doesn't know how to pass along
what he's learned and that he can't
handle the burden of what it might mean
if he fails iceman communicating mostly
through a computer because of his
illness responds by typing it's time to
let go this means many things in the
wider context of the film it means it's
time for maverick to let go of the guilt
he feels for losing goose and for what
he did to rooster earlier in his career
it means it's time for him to let go of
the life he used to have and it means
it's time for him to let go of the fear
that he's going to inadvertently cause
more loss of both lives and careers
iceman re-emphasizes this point more
than once in the conversation leaving
maverick with the conclusion that he
simply has to learn how by the end of
the film maverick has seemingly let all
of it go he's no longer afraid of losing
who he is or what he does
or of letting down the people around
he's able to take his own advice stop
thinking about it and just do it and in
the end that might be the most important
thematic through line of top gun
maverick check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]